I was tremendously impressed when you
were dating Emily radakowski I think I
was very impressed okay like I'm like
way to go Eric like [__] that's awesome
and then it ended kind of suddenly and
nobody knows what happened but here's my
fantasy you're just too [__] crazy I
mean she was probably like scared like
dug you and everything and you're funny
but like you know you just probably
brought out the two big [__] tanks of
whip it and she's like what the [__]
this is like a madman
that's what I think happened do you do
you go there with me and tell me is that
what happened that she just said hey
look Eric you're a great guy but I think
we should be friends the nitrous tank
yeah the nitrous tanks came out she was
like I've had enough is that true is
that true no no so did you [__] up that
situation
a gentleman never tells Howard I know I
don't want I'm not listening I would
suspect the privacy and boundaries of
who's on your radar next what celebrity
will you date next Michelle Obama is
whatever really yeah yeah I think if I
can date Michelle if I can get her to
break up with Barack do you find now
when you walk in the room a different
level of woman now looks at you
I do I I don't I don't know the answer
is yes
oh no I don't
know oh man I don't know
I checked very well no kidding yeah he's
on a tear serious question Eric do you
think you could be married one day with
a family or is it I think so I think
it's time I think it's time really yeah
you're getting the urge I'm getting the
issue
baby kids maybe
kids is a big responsibility are you up
to that I think so
can you still do this and be a dad I
think so
are you in love now I am
you are yeah well congratulations that's
fabulous when did this happen I'm dating
Megan Merkel I knew it
I knew it is her husband pissed he
doesn't know he doesn't know and we're
gonna keep it that way
I'm hanging out I'm hanging out so
you're in love with someone I'm hanging
I'm getting to know somebody you know
why I like hearing that because I feel
like you have such a wild existence yeah
fact that you could open up your heart
and be loving and be in a good
relationship I think it'd be good for
you yeah you got to you got to have that
a woman in your life he brings you
balance your life is out of balance
without without that in your life
foreign